welcome back y'all my next guest is one
of the best selling authors on the
planet since her debut novel in 2012 she
has sold over 40 million books and
redefine the fantasy genre her latest is
House of flame and Shadow the third book
in her Crescent City series this is
amazing actually just check this out how
many people actually showed up to her
midnight release party last week it's
like Taylor Swift went somewhere it's
like crazy is that normal by the way
like last night I I mean even vulture
wrote something about you like you did
this release and like it just blew up it
literally was like Taylor Swit was
releasing an album like it all these
people showed up is that normal um I
guess you feel like a tool answering
that is yeah I was like wait that's a
weird question but I mean that's amazing
imp you know this was actually my first
event like in-person event since Co um
yeah so this was kind of like my first
time like back in the flesh well by the
way you're in demand look at that like
well that's you're doing doing it right
it was amazing it was just amazing being
out there and like seeing the readers
face to face again after so many years
and um and you've created this world
like whichever series you know they're
addicted to or into like you've cre this
whole world that y'all are all a part of
that's really cool yeah no it just it's
I mean it still feels like a dream come
true like I wanted to be a writer since
I was 16 years old that's amazing
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home